わかった、そしてあなたはナンバー3の鷹匠です、
わかった、あなたがそこにいることを完全に感じています バッカーノは
ゲームチェンジャーです、私はいつも
人々に、クエンティン・
タランティーノがまさにアニメを作ったかのようだと言います、
特に会話は大丈夫です、そして番号は私自身ではこれ以上うまく表現できませんでした
Fate Zero 2つ待ってください、その2、
どこに置くのがいいですか、
そこにあります、もちろんです、ええと、
個人的にはモンスターの後ろに置きます、
彼はいつもヨハンのことを思っていました、ははは、
非常に面白い、わかりましたドラムロール、ギガは何を
考えていますか？ 史上最高のアニメ よく
知ってるでしょう デーモン スレイヤー ジーザス クライスト
エヴァ エヴァ エヴァンゲリオンの
ドーガン もう一人のエヴァ 分かった 分かった 待ってね、あなたは
エヴァを見たでしょ、ああ、違う、私は
それを見ました、そしてあなたはそれが好きでしたか、いいえ、私はそれを愛しています
世界は宗教的なテーマを構築している
奇妙なフロイト主義がメッカの雰囲気を醸し出しているが、実際には
メッカのデザインではないが、犬が出てくると
エンディングだ エヴァンゲリオンは第25話
まででこれまでに作られた最高のアニメだ
ローガン、我々はそこには行かない
どうやって50話にピボットできるだろうか
物語のクライマックスでの数分間の内部対話、
なんてことだ、あなたは完全に要点を逸脱しており
、
子供に意見をスプーンで与えたくなかったが、それが
重要なら、なぜエヴァンゲリオンの終わりを作るのは
それが本来のものではないのか 本当の
結末は、すでに着陸に行き詰まっている場合はやり直しません。
それがこの映画の天才の一部であり、
適切な結末を求めるあなたのような狂人に、
同時に不安を解消しながら噛む何かを与えます。
「不安じゃないですか、
すべてのシリーズが完璧な
シンデレラストーリーの展開をする必要があるわけではないことはわかりませんか？彼らはThe Landingに固執しましたか、それとも
精神疾患の経験はありますか？
ええ、実際、私は完璧主義者であり、
妻は私にそう言っています」 慢性的な先
延ばし癖のあるローガンはダメだよ、
エヴァンゲリオンのプロットも説明してよ、
これは過去 20 年間
に Ava ファンなら誰でも聞いたことのある一次元的な批評と同じだ、
優れたストーリーテリングには必要なものだ、
君は本当に YouTube 動画で Ava を分析しようとしているのか？
アリストテレスの詩学を観た 何かを観たことはなかった
エヴァをこんなに
素晴らしいものにしているのは、庵野がシリーズ全体で自分の精神をどのように捉えたかということだ
重要なのは
それを理解することではなく、その感情に共鳴することだ
しかし、それならなぜシンジは、そして
あなたがしがみついている限り あなたの狭い
視野では、傑作の
底を見つけることが特別な気分になるからです。
ズームアウトして、実際にそれが傑作である理由を確認することは決してできません。大丈夫、私
は詩学というクリフノートと呼ばれる本をよく読みました、
私は読んでいませんでした
後の映画も観てみたことがあります、そうですね、
映画を一度観たら、
すべてが終わった背後にある本当の結末がわかると思います、それで、
新しい映画を観た後は、すべてが意味をなすはずです、
いいえ